sie führen einen David gegen
goliath-kampf wollen gegen die Politik
der Regierung mobil machen eine kleine
Buchhandlung in tellerassy Florida
queere Jugendliche wie der 18-jährige
Schüler will larkins beschreiben ihre
Sorgen wenn Bücher über Menschen wie sie
selbst in Schulbibliotheken verboten
werden
schon in der vierten Klasse glaubte ich
dass ich zerbrochen war was kein
Viertklässler fühlen sollte aber das ist
eine fast universelle Erfahrung und der
queeren Menschen vor allem transmenschen
wenn sie gar nicht wissen dass es noch
andere Leute wie sie gibt
und ein Weg wie diese Kinder Trost und
eine Community finden können sind die
Bücher die sie jetzt aus den Regalen
nehmen
[Applaus]
in der Bejahung meiner Person durch
diese Bücher habe ich unsagbare Freude
gefunden plötzlich schienen die Jungs
die mich schikaniert haben unbedeutender
denn es gab da draußen noch mehr
Menschen wie mich eine Zukunft hat sich
auf wo ich stolz ich selbst sein könnte
weit weg von diesem trostlosen Ort
deshalb ist es so wichtig diese Bücher
in den Regalen zu haben es rettet Leben
denn die Bücher die aus den Regalen der
Schulen verschwinden drehen sich vor
allem um zwei Gruppen die lgbtq-
insgesamt geht es darum alles zu
unterdrücken wo Minderheiten dargestellt
werden sie wollen weiße
Heteronormativität als Standard
einrichten wir haben das in der
Geschichte ja schon gesehen wie in
Deutschland wo die arische Rasse
durchgesetzt werden sollte es beginnt
mit der Zensur bestimmter Minderheiten
wir müssen wachsam sein und dagegen
kämpfen damit das nicht voranschreitet
Lehrer haben Angst sie räumen die Regale
lieber leer als möglicherweise ein Buch
zu übersehen das nicht mehr erlaubt ist
und sich damit strafbar zu machen
sie verhängen die Regale Bücher werden
unsichtbar
wir wurden instruiert dass wir drei
Möglichkeiten haben für die Bücher in
unseren Klassenzimmern wir konnten sie
entweder ganz wegpacken oder sie mit
Papier oder ähnlichem abhängen
oder aber jedes einzelne Buch mit einer
Datenbank des Schulbezirks abgleichen in
der erlaubte Bücher aufgelistet sind
und wenn ein Buch darin verzeichnet war
durfte es offen im Regal bleiben
so will es rondes Säntis Gouverneur von
Florida und hat dieses Verfahren
gesetzlich festgeschrieben er sieht den
Kampf gegen das liberale Amerika als
Blaupause für die ganzen USA Abtreibung
künftig bereits ab der sechsten
schwangerschaftswoche verboten über
Geschlechter Identität darf in Floridas
Schulen selbst in der Oberstufe nicht
mehr gesprochen werden die kritische
Auseinandersetzung mit systemischem
Rassismus in Schulen untersagt
wir finden es wichtig dass die Bildung
sich auf das Wesentliche konzentriert
deswegen haben wir kritische
Rassentheorie für alle Jahrgangsstufen
verboten wir benutzen ihre Steuergelder
nicht um unseren Kindern beizubringen
unser Land zu hassen wir haben auch
sichergestellt dass Eltern die
Lehrinhalte prüfen können so dass sie
wissen was ihre Kinder lernen und
Einspruch erheben können
bei den öffentlichen Veranstaltungen der
Schulbehörden wird viel diskutiert
nachdem der Treue Schuhe zur Flagge
gesprochen ist ein denkwürdiger Auftritt
der hundertjährigen Witwe Grace Lyn ihr
Ehemann war im Zweiten Weltkrieg
gefallen
Bücher verbieten und Bücher verbrennen
ist dasselbe
beides geschieht aus dem gleichen Grund
Angst vor wissen
Angst ist nicht Freiheit
Angst ist Kontrolle
ein deutliches Zeichen dagegen setzt die
vielfach ausgezeichnete Autorin Margaret
Edward ihr Roman der Report der Markt in
dem christliche Fundamentalisten
herrschen und Frauen vollständig
unterwerfen attackiert verboten in
vielen Schulbezirken Amerikas jetzt in
feuerfester Ausgabe weil machtvolle
Worte niemals ausgelöscht werden können
insbesondere Bücher mit sexuellen
Inhalten über geschlechtliche
Selbstfindung Bücher zu Rassismus sind
ins Visier eifriger Eltern geraten
selbst der amerikanische Klassiker to
kill a Mockingbird der sich um den
Rassismus der 50er Jahre in den USA
dreht wurde als Schullektüre in Frage
gestellt
the blue ist ei von Nobelpreisträgerin
Tony Morrison indem die schwarze
Hauptfigur vergewaltigt wird aus
Büchereien verbannt
ebenso wie Maus die grafische
Auseinandersetzung Arzt beaglemans mit
dem Holocaust weil darin gezeichnete
Brüste zu sehen sind
Mütter wie Jennifer Pippin wollen genau
das die Schule als Vehikel für ein
ausschließlich traditionelles
Gesellschaftsbild sie entscheidet selbst
was ihre Teenager lesen dürfen
ich lasse sie Bücher lesen die sie wegen
ihrer Hobbys interessieren
mein Sohn angelt gerne also besorge ich
im Bücher übers Angeln und jagen meine
Tochter möchte Kriminalbeamtin werden
oder Anwältin also hole ich hier Bücher
über das Strafrecht und wo das Blut
spritzt und sowas ich habe nicht das
Gefühl dass sexuell freizügige Inhalte
sie zu besseren Menschen machen
aus Ihrem privaten Anliegen ist ein
gesellschaftliches geworden mit der
rechtsgerichteten Organisation MamS for
liberty treibt sie die Verbote voran sie
ist in einem Komitee das im Auftrag der
Regierung entwickelt hat wie die Bücher
geprüft werden und zeigt uns was aus den
Regalen verschwinden soll
diese Zettel sind stellen die sexuell
sehr deutlich sind oder anderweitig
völlig unangemessen für Kinder
es heißt gender queer es wurde im ganzen
Land in Grundschulen in der Mittelstufe
und Oberstufe gefunden
sie sind nackt erfasst seinen Penis an
sie sprechen über Oralsex Entschuldigung
wir sind hier ja in einer Kinderbücherei
längst geht es nicht mehr nur um
Bedenken einzelner Eltern es hat sich
eine Bewegung gebildet von
Organisationen wie MamS for liberty die
Teil eines Kulturkampfes sind die
Geschichten hinter den patriotischen
Symbolen Amerikas das sind Bücher wie
sie sich des Säntis und seine
kulturkämpfer wünschen hier an der
tellerassy classical School sollen die
Kinder nicht verwirrt werden durch
unsere allzu komplexe Realität alles
soll sein wie in den vermeintlich guten
jedenfalls alten Zeiten
kurz nach unserem Besuch wurde die
Direktorin zum Rücktritt gezwungen weil
sie im Kunstunterricht die bekannteste
Skulptur der Kunstgeschichte gezeigt hat
den David von Michelangelo und empörte
Eltern nicht unterscheiden konnten
zwischen Nacktheit und Pornografie
verspricht eine einfache und fromme Welt
in der die die vermeintlich anders sind
draußen bleiben sollen
es ist beängstigend aber letztlich
glaube ich nicht dass ronde Säntis
bekommt was er will wir sind schon zu
weit gekommen Florida wird die Kurve
kriegen es ist wie bei einer
Steinschleuder Sie versuchen zu ziehen
so weit es irgendwie geht aber je weiter
sie zurückziehen desto schneller werden
wir nach vorne gehen in eine bessere
Zukunft in der alle sicher sind
nicht nur hier meinen sie ronde Säntis
gehe zu weit selbst viele Konservative
empfinden das inzwischen so seine
Umfragewerte für die Präsidentschaft
sinken denn unliebsame Realitäten per
Gesetz zu verbieten könnte auch dem Rest
Amerikas zu extrem zu autoritär sein
[Musik]